[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض نبدا وهاب العلوي
على وقائع الاعدامات المانيا تستدعي سفير
طهران يصف ايران بالتحدي الاكبر
ذا بوست استعد للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي
مشاركه وفد سعوديه رفيع برئاسه وزير
الخارجيه
الرابعه توثيق اليه الترجمه في القضاء
السعوديه 47 لغه لتسهيل فهم المتقاضين
الاحكام
في الرابعه ايضا
ضمن مبادره ضخمه بدوي عمليات التشجير في
ساحات ومرافق المسجد الحرام
عام مليء بالاحداث الرياضيه في السعوديه
برشلونه بطلا لسوبر وختام والذكر
في موقف يعبر عن تعزم العلاقات بين ايران
ودول الاوروبيه اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه
الالمانيه استدعاء السفير الايراني للمره
الثانيه خلال اسبوع بسبب عمليات الاعدام
التي تنفذها
المتحدث باسم الخارجيه الى المانيا
في مجال حقوق الانسان
وقد كده المتحدث باسم الاتحاد الاوروبي
بيترستانو بان المفاوضات مع ايران بشان
الاتفاق النووي لا تسير في الاتجاه الصحيح
وقال المسؤول الاوروبي ان وزراء خارجيه
الاتحاد يبحثون لاتفاق النوويه مع ايران
الا ان القمر الذي تمارسه ضد المحتجين
وتعمها لروسيا عسكريا هما امران يضاعفان
تعقيدات المحادثات
هذا وتشهد الان مدينه ستراسبورغ الفرنسيه
تظاهرات حاشده او تظاهره
مبنى البرلمان الاوروبي استجابه لدعوات
اطلقها عدد من الناشطين وسياسيين
الايرانيين في الخارج المعارضين للنظام
الايراني وذلك بهدف مطالبه الاتحاد
الاوروبي وجميع الحكومات الاوروبيه بتصنيف
الحرس الثوريه الايراني منظمه الارهابيه
من امام مقر البرلمان الاوروبي ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه
وهل من شخصيات شهيره ايضا تشارك في هذه
المسيح
اهلا خالد التظاهرا انطلقت بالفعل والان
وصلت الى امام مقر همم مجلس الاوروبي
البرلمان الاوروبي في مدينه ستراسبور
شرقيه فرنسا المتظاهرون الان يسيرون وهم
يهتفون ضد الجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
يطلقون هتافات مؤيده للثوره ويطالبون بان
يدرج الحارس السوري الايراني على قائمه
المنظمات الارهابيه طبعا هذا التحرك اليوم
يشارك به عدد كبير من المتظاهرين الالاف
حقيقه جاءوا من حوالي 50 مدينه اوروبيه
خالد واطلق هذه الدعوه للتظاهر نائب سويدي
من اصل ايراني اسمه علي رضا اخوتي كان هو
صاحب فكره هذا التحرك الذي ياتي ايضا
بالتزامن مع اجتماع
البرلمان الاوروبي غدا حيث سيتم بحث همم
مساله همم حزمه حزمه عقوبات جديده على همم
ايران
وبعدها رفع هذه التوصيات الى اجتماع وزراء
الخارجيه الاوروبيين المقرر في الثالث
والعشرين من هذا الشهر طبعا هذا القرار
سيكون له اهميه كبيره لان الاتحاد
الاوروبي حتى وان كان هو قد قام بفرض
عقوبات على ايران وبدراج عدد من شخصيات
الحارس السوري الايراني
تبقى فرديه او العقوبات تنقض ضد اشخاص اا
وليست ضد كيان مثل الحارس الثوري الايراني
همم خلال العشر سنوات الماضيه كان هناك
عقوبات كثيره همم جميله التقييد حركه
اموال 19 شخصيه متورطه بالقمع واعضاء في
الحارس الثوري الايراني المتظاهرون اليوم
يحاولون الضغط في هذا الاتجاه في اتجاه ان
يتم همم تصنيف الحارس الدوري الايراني
حتى المنظمات الارهابيه في دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي طبعا كما ذكرت هناك عدد كبير
المئات جاو من مختلف الدول الاوروبيه
شاهدنا لافتات كان يحملها عدد من
المواطنين الايرانيين المعارضين الذين
جاءوا من بريطانيا كتب عليها رسائل
للبرلمانيين الاوروبيين الذين سوف يجتمعون
غدا من بين هذه الرسائل فويس
[موسيقى]
في تصنيف الحارس السوري الايراني
من الذي ينظم هذه التظاهره وما حجم الدعم
الذي تجده اوروبيا فادي
التظاهره تنظم بالاساس بدعوه من نائب
سويدي من اصل ايراني هو متواجد هنا بين
المتظاهرين وايضا من قبل العدد كبير من
المنظمات
الشخصيات الايرانيه المعارضه الذين دعوا
لهذه التظاهره حجم المتظاهرين كبير جدا
هناك الالام في شوارع مدينه
اكثر امام مقر البرلمان الاوروبي هنا في
شرق فرنسا كلهم جاءوا من عواصم اوروبيه
همم مختلفه
المتظاهرين هناك وايضا كما ذكرت لي مطالبه
الان ياتي فون حريه حريه يهتفون ايضا مراه
حريه او حياه الهتاف الشهير الذي كانوا او
يطلقونه في كل تظاهراتهم هناك ايضا ضد
خامنئي يقولون مات مات خامين
وهدى فات مات الديكتاتور التي
توجه لخامنا ايضا هناك ايضا عدد من
المتظاهرين الذين يحملون مشانق كما ترونهم
على الشاشه هؤلاء همم يحملون هذه
المشانق في صوره رمزيه للاعدامات التي
حدثت مؤخرا في ايران وهي ربما كانت سببا
رئيسيا في همم
من
السياسيين الاوروبيين في همم الطلب في همم
ضروره ان يدرج الحارس الثوري الايراني على
قائمه المنظمات العراقيه وايضا همم
تتشدد الدول الاوروبيه اكثر في دعمها واضح
للمعارضه الايرانيه وايضا في عقوباتها ضد
النظام الايراني
مراسل العربيه من امام البرلمان الاوروبي
في استراسبر
على صعيد ان اخر كذا رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين التانياه وان ايران
ستبقى ستبقى التحدي الاكبر لاسرائيل
وجيشها وخلال مراسم التعيين رئيس اركان
الجيش الجديد هيرسي
اكدانه يهوى اسرائيل الايراني
الاداريه ينضم الينا الباحث في الشان
الايراني وجدان عبد الرحمن سيد وجدان
مرحبا بكم معنا تابعت المشهد معي قبل قليل
من ستراسبورغ امام البرلمان الاوروبي
مسيره المظاهرات تطالب بتصنيف الحرس
الثوري منظمه الارهابيه 1 محاسبه النظام
لكن هل يمكن فعليه على خطوات
اوروبيه اكثر التشددا وصرامه لمحاسبه
النظام يعني بعد خطوه استدعاء السفير
الايراني مثلا في المانيا
تحياتي لك يا استاذ خالد متابعيك الكرام
دون ادنى اشياء سيكون لهذه التظاهرات
تاثير كبير على قرار البرلمان
الاوروبيرج وخاصه بعد ما شاهدنا
التظاهر الكبيره التي ااا اندلعت في برلين
والتي تجاوز عددها 80000 كل الاحصائيه
الالمانيه كان لها تاثير الكبير على
الكثير من القرارات في
المانيا وايضا التاثير على نواب برلمانيين
همم وعلى دول اوروبيه اخرى لذلك هذه
التظاهر دون شاشه تكون داعم كبير لقرار
اخوندي النائبه السويدي منه وصول ايرانيه
لحذف البرلمانيين الاوروبيين للمصادقه على
ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني كم منظمه
ارهابيه
وهذا التصنيف همم يعد امرا همم
ونجاحا كبيرا بالنسبه للمعارضه لان همم
علاقه ايران التجاريه مع الدول الغربيه هي
تكمن مع الدول الاتحاد الاوروبي بالتحديد
وليس مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لذلك
ادراج حرس الحدود الايراني الذي يهيم على
الاقتصاد الايراني بشكل كبير ااه يقطع كل
العلاقات الاقتصاديه والتجاريه بين دول
الاتحاد وايران وبالتحديد المانيا التي
شاهدنا ان هنالك تبادل التجاري كبير كان
لها مع ايران ما الذي يمنع هذه الدول الان
او يجعلها متردده ربما في اتخاذ خطوه اكثر
تقدما لمحاسبه النظام يتحدث بشكل مباشر عن
الحرس الثوري الايراني ومساله تصنيفه
منظمه الارهابي
اتصور هنالك بعض الدول الاوروبيه
وخاصه الشركات الكبرى منها شركات الطيران
وايضا
الشركات النفط في الدول
الاوروبيه بصراحه هي
التي تضغط على دوالها لتريد ان تستثمر في
ايران ولا تريد ان تترك المجال للروس و
الصينيين
للاستثمار في الاقتصاد الايراني لذلك هي
هذه الشركات تلعب دور كبير في هذا المجال
لا تجعل الدول ما زالت تتعامل مع النظام
الايراني لكن ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه الارهابي يفقد هذه الشركات همم
امتيازاتها في الداخل همم الايراني
ويجعل الحرس همم بعيدا عن الاقتصاد
الايراني الدول الاوروبيه البعض منها ايضا
ما زالت تعتقد بانه يمكن للنظام الايراني
السيطره على الاحتجاجات والعوده من جديد
كدوله يعني يمكن التعامل الاقتصادي مع
الهام ما زالت تطمع الى هذا الامر ولكن
هذه الحاسبات بصراحه اذا كان يظن فهي غلط
شكرا
بعد قليل النيابه العامه في السعوديه تعلن
مصادره ثلاثه ملايين و300 الف ريال
لوافدين او وافدين التهم بغسل الاموال
اهلا بكم من جديد تسهيل لعمليه التقاضي
والترفع التي يحتاجها الوافدين في
السعوديه قام مركز الترجمه الموحد في
وزاره العدل السعوديه بترجمه نحو اثنين او
اثنتين وخمسين الف جلسه خلال العام الماضي
يقدم المركز الترجمه
52,000 جلسه قضائيه تمكن مركز ترجمه
الموحد في وزاره العدل السعوديه من
ترجمتها خلال العام الماضي حيث اتاح
المركز للمستفيدين التقاضي بالصوت والصوره
عبر نظام الالكتروني عن بعد بمختلف اللغات
وبسريه تامه
برنامج التحول الوطني والتي تعمل وتساهم
في تحقيق العداله الناجزه للمستفيدين
الخارجيين بالاضافه للضمانات القضائيه
وتسريع نسبه الانجاز القضايا الخاصه
باطراف الدعوى لغير نعتقين باللغه العربيه
يمكن المركز غير الناطقين باللغه العربيه
من متابعه قضاياهم من خلال مترجمين
يتحدثون سبع واربعين لغه من مختلف لغات
العالم ويربط المركز بين قاعات المحاكم
والسجون وفقا انظمه تقنيه دقيقه
اللغه الانجليزيه والصينيه
والاسبانيه
والاكثر طلبا اللغه الارديه تقديم الطلبات
هي بشكل يسير والص بسيط وسهل ويتم من خلال
منصه تقاضي ترجمه
ينشا الطلب اولا من خلال صحيفه الدعوه في
ناجز ثم ياتي الى تحيه الدعوه ثم لتدقيق
الدعوه وانتشر الى وين يذهب الى
الدائره القضائيه
القانونيه الشائعه في المحاكم السعوديه
ابرز الاسس التي يتم تدريب المترجمين
عليها لضمان خدمه افضل للمتقاضين من كل
الجنسيات واللغات غاده الفهد العربيه
الريق
بعد ثبوت جريمه الممارسه بغسيل الاموال
كشفت نيابه العامه في السعوديه عن مصادره
اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين و 300 الف ريال نقدا
لوافدين
المتهمين صدر بحقهما حكم قضائي بالسجن
لمده ست سنوات مع غرامه ماليه قدرت ب 200
الف ريال وابعادهما عن البلاد فورا
مركز الملك سلمان الاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه مشروعا يعنى بدعم المشاكل
والنظام الصحي في السودان وذلك من خلال
التسليم عدد من اجهزه التنفس الصناعي
للمشافي في ولايه الخرطوم في خطوه تاتي
ضمن مرحله اولى من المشروع الذي يتكون من
10 مراحل او من عشر مراحل في اطار الدعم
الانساني الى السودان
في السودان علي بن حسن جعفر ان دعم
الانساني لمشروع النظام الصحي في السودان
ياتي من الباب الاغاثي على ان تستمر هذه
المبادرات ومتى ما استدعت الحاجه لذلك
تعمل انساني ياتي طبعا في اطار ما تقدموا
حكومه خادم الحرمين الشريفين من دعم
انساني في كافه المجالات
الاغاثيه والانشطه الانسانيه اللي همم
الشعب السوداني
وتستمر هذه
المساعدات انطلاقا من الحوت التي
ننسق فيها مع الاجهزه السودانيه
الدوري ذكر وزير الصحه السودانيه المكلف
هيثم محمد للاجهزه الصحيه تم شرائها من
السوق المحلي وهو الامر الذي سيضمن
استمراريتها لمده تصل الى 10 سنوات ما
يؤكد نجاحها في المرحله الاولى الى جانب
الدعم السعوديه
في ولايه الخرطوم باعتباره بتستقبل اكبر
عدد من المرضى خاصه المرضى الحالات الحرجه
يميز المشروع انه الاجهزه تم شرائها من
السوق هل هو ده بيضمن التشغيل وبضمن همم
الاستمراريه والتدريب والاستفراد بضمان
لمده همم 10 سنوات همم يؤدي حقيقه لانه
نجاحا المشروع ومستقبل المشروع وبالتالي
يمكننا بعداك همم
تنفيذ بقيه المشروع في باقي المستشفيات
وباقي الولايات
وكما تم الاتحاق كذلك مع الاخ السفير انه
همم نحن همم عمره مع مركز الملك سلمان
اكتب لي المشاريع القادمه في خطه يتفق
عليها طرفين
في مكه المكرمه بدات تعملوا التشجير في
ساحات ومرافق المسجد الحرام ضمن مبادره
اطلقت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين المبادره تهدف
الى تحسين البيئه العامه بالمسجد الحرام
وساحات التابعه له باستغلال المساحات
الخاليه والممرات وتحويل اجزاء منها الى
احواض زراعيه كما تهدف هذه المبادره الى
استغلال مياه الوضوء ومعالجتها وتدويرها
والاستفاده منها في رؤيه تلك المسطحات
والهجره
من الحرم المكي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
سلطان السلمي حدثنا اكثر ااا بعد الترحيب
بك طبعا سلطان حدثنا اكثر عن هذه المبادره
وكيف يتم العمل على تنفيذه
اهلا بك خالد اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل بدات الرئاسه العامه
للشؤون الحرمين برفقه عدد من القطاعات
الحكوميه المهتمه بقطاع الزراعه بعمل
التشجير وزراعه بعض النباتات في حول
الساحات الحرم المكي والاماء والمواقع
المفتوحه ضمن النطاق الحرم اريد ان يلقيكم
ونلقي نظرا على بعض من هذه المبادره
والعمل على التسجيل وزراعه النباتات في
الساحات تعتبر الشماليه اللي هي الحرم
المكي وهي جزء من هذه المبادره والمشروع
من خلال وضع هذه النباتات في اماكن مرتفعه
بعيده عن متناول الايدي وذلك لاهداف عديده
منها لتعزيز جوده الهواء وكذلك لراحه
المعتمرين والمصلين وزوار المسجد الحرام
من خلف هذه
الشجيرات وهذه النباتات التي تم اختيارها
وفق ضوابط محدده من ضمنها نتحدث على بعض
هذه الضوابط المهمه التي
او نتحدث بدايه عن المساحات ونتحدث عن
7344 متر مربع من المساحات الخاليه بواقع
تحدث على 25 موقع نتحدث على مواقع
المقاربه لاسلام الكهربائيه والاسقف
العاليه وكذلك من الاستفاده منها من خلال
النشر الظل وكذلك اضافه زياده الاكسجين في
مساحات المفتوحه او شبه مغلقه في الحرم
هنالك جهات عديده او لجنه شكلت لهذه العام
او هذا المشروع تحدث عن الرئاسه العامه
لشؤون الحرمين وايضا المركز الوطني لتنميه
الغطاء النباتي وكذلك معهد ابحاث الحج
والعمره بجامعه ام القرى هنالك ضوابط
محدده ان من خلال الاستبعاد استقطاع اي
مساحات من المصليات او ما يؤثر على مسارات
حركه الحشود لذلك المشاهدها في اماكن
مرتفعه ايضا لا تكون هذه النباتات لها اي
جذور عميقه وبالتالي يعني تؤثر بشكل او
باخر على البنيه التحتيه للمسجد الحرام
بسبب وجود تمديدات ومسالات الخدمات ايضا
الا تكون هذه النباتات هي جاذبه الحشرات
او حتى الافات وبالتالي لا تؤثر على صحه
قاصدي المسجد الحرام اليوم هذه المبادره
تسعى في جوانب عديده منها كبيره جدا من
خلال العمل على هذه المبادره من ضمنها
تعزيز الغطاء النباتي لما له اثر ايجابي
في تحسين اجانب البيئي الذي ينعكس ايجابا
بطبيعه الحال على زوار المسجد الحرام هذه
هي المرحله الاولى سوف تشهد المواقع
مختلفه ومناطق مختلفه من المسجد الحرام
مثل هذه الاشكال من خلال استغلال كافه
المساحات الخاليه في المسجد الساحات
ومقابل الابواب والسلامه الكهربائيه وكذلك
الاسقف المعلقه نعم خالد
من الحرم المكي الشريف
فصل القصير وتابعوا بعده الرابعه
اهلا بكم في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
انطلق ملتقى تطوير ممكنات صناعه التحليه
يشارك في الملتقى على مدى ثلاثه ايام اكثر
من 60 متحدثا محليا ودوليا
الى تعزيز التوطين قطاع تحليه المياه
والمساهمه في خفض تكلفه عمليات التحليه
كما يظن معرض صناعه التحليه في السعوديه
والذي يروي رحله تحليه يا منذ بدايتها
وحتى اليوم
اليوم كان للمؤتمر عده اهداف استراتيجيه
ومنها كيف ممكن نجيب الخبرات سواء المحليه
والعالميه بحيث نتشارك الافكار في صناعه
التحليه من الخبراء والمختصين سواء
المحليين او العالميين اما في ما يخص
الابتكارات فالطرقنا العديد من الابتكارات
وممكن اهمها كيف ممكن نحسن موانع اليوم
المؤسسه العامه عندها خبرات متراكمه نتكلم
على اكثر من 47 سنه كيف ممكن نستغل هذه
الخبرات بحيث ننتج جديد همم او موانع تسرب
جديده همم تساعدنا في تحسين همم كفاءه
المنتج او المياه المنتجه همم بشكل او اخر
الملتقى عندنا ملتقى الان لمده ثلاث ايام
بتبدا اليوم الهدف منه يسلط الضوء على
ابرز ممكنات واا يعني ابرز ممكنات صناعه
التحليه
وبالاضافه الى انه يجمع خبراء ومهتمين
بصناعه التحليه الان اا بيكون في عده
جلسات
حواريه وبعض
اللقاءات اللي يكون كلها هدف منها
دراسه ونقاش صناعه التحيه وممكناتها
بالاضافه الى تطوير التقنيات بما يخص
صناعه التحيات
انطلقوا في دافوس السويسري اليوم المنتدى
الاقتصادي العالمي وسط حضور قياسي من
الشخصيات الحكوميه والقطاع الخاص حيث
سيتضمن 52 رئيس دوله وحكومه الى جانب 56
وزيرا للماليه واكثر من 600 رئيس تنفيذي
الماضيه التي ستتهايمن على المنتدى هي
المخاطر قصيره الاجل مثل ارتفاع تكاليف
المعيشه وكيفيه التجنب حدوث ركود عالمي
هذا العام وتراجع جهود مكافحه التغير
المناخي
هذا هو سيشاركه في الاجتماع السنوي
للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي 2023 في تنافس
بسويسرا وبدون سعودي رفيع المستوى برئاسه
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ويضم الوفد وزير الدوله للشؤون
الخارجيه والمبعوث لشؤون المناخ عادل
الجبير سفيره السعوديه لدى الولايات
المتحده الاميره ريما بنت بندر اضافه الى
وزراء الاستثمار والماليه والاتصالات
وتقنيه المعلومات والصناعه والثروه
المعدنيه والاقتصاد والتخطيط فضلنا عن
الرئيس التنفيذي للهيئه الملكيه لمدينه
الرياض
ده فستان العربيه لارحبيب لارا مرحبا بك
ترى اولا يعني
الاطلالات الخلابه ربما للجبال الالب كيف
ستكون يعني في في واقع ربما مثقل بالكثير
من الازمات في مناقشات المشاركين فيها
ماذا على جدول الاعمال هذه المره
صباح الخير
المدينه الجميله السويسريه اعلى مدينه في
اوروبا
يعني عنوان المنتدى هذا المنتدى الذي يعود
في صيغته الشتويه لاول مره منذ الجائحه
لانه في العام الماضي ان عقد في شهر مايو
ينعقد تحت شعار التعاون في عالم منقسم
ماذا يعني ذلك يعني كل الازمات اللي مر
بها العالم في السنوات الماضيه واتحدث هنا
عن الازمات الصحيه ازمه الطاقه اثبت
الاقتصاد ازمه كوفد بالطبع ازمه التضخم
وغلاء المعيشه كل ذلك ادى الى اجراءات
حمائيه من قبل الدول بعكس العولمه
المنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي منذ تاسيسه
وبالتالي الان ربما يجب ان نرى نوع جديد
من التعاون لحل هذه المشاكل المترابطه ما
بين
لانه اكيد مثلا مشكله التضخم هي بسبب
ارتفاع اسعار الطاقه اللي هي بسبب همم
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه من احد اسباب
همم حل هذه المشاكل يجب ان تكون همم
لحلول المستدامه يجب ان تكون من خلال
تعاون بين الدول وايضا تعاون بين القطاعين
العام والخاص وهذا ما يركز عليه المنتدى
همم هذا ما قاله رئيس المنتدى كلاو شواب
لقاء الحضور همم واللقاء بشكل شخص هو
ضروري
لاعاده الثقه بين الاطراف المعينه
والخروج من هذه العقليه العقليه الازمات
اللي ضغط على المنتدى همم ربما نلفته هذا
العام
المشاركه الاكبر من الدول الناشئه الهند
مثلا لها مشاركه قويه كوريا الجنوبيه لها
مشاركه هنا من اخرى همم ربما الملفد غياب
رؤساء دول الاقتصادات الكبرى ما عدا
المستشار الالماني شولز همم وايضا هناك
حضور لرئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه عدا عن
ذلك ما شفنا رؤساء دول
للاقتصادات الكبرى يعني رئيس جروفايدن
غائب هنا الرئيس مكروه وغير من الرؤساء
ايضا همم فيما يتعلق بالحضور بالروسي
بالطبع للسنه الثانيه ليس هناك اي حضور
للملياردات الروس اللي تعودنا نشوف بدافه
السنه همم بسبب الازمه هناك كلمه منتظره
ايضا هذا العام الرئيس اوكرانيا وايضا من
المتوقع حضور زوجه
الى المنتدى بشكل شخصيه ومن المفترض ان
ايضا يكون لها همم كلمه لحاسه الدول
لمساعده اوكرانيا وارسال همم بطبع الاسلحه
والمزيد من الاسلحه ب- بالطبع هذا امر انه
تبعه بالاضافه الى كلمه شولت همم المستشار
الالماني والى كلمه همم ارسل لافوندريا
عن حضور الملياردورات ربما يعني دافوس
مشهور على مدى سنوات ماضيه باجتماع
لارديرات من كل انحاء العالم هناك غياب
كما ذكرت ربما
للطبقه المليارديره الروس بحكم الحرب لكن
ماذا عن الصينيين هل هناك حضور هل هناك
اختلاف في قائمه الشخصيات المدعوه هل من
المتوقع نشهد يعني اجتماعات همم
[موسيقى]
تسفر عن صفقات او غيرها
ربما خالد الملفت هذا العام في عوده لبعض
الملياردورات او لرؤساء الشركات الكبرى
اللي لم يحضروا دافوس في مايو الماضي
اتحدث هنا عن رؤساء شركات الكبرى في وورلد
لهم حضور قوي جدا هنا
احد اكبر المؤسسات الماليه حول العالم
يعودون الى ذهب فيما يتعلق بالتمثيل
الصيني نائب رئيس الحكومه متواجد هنا ولكن
ربما تمثيل ليس بكبير احنا بنعرف انه كان
في اجراءات وقيود على الحركه في الصين
رفعت همم منذ ايام قليله وبالتالي هذا الى
تقلص الوفد اضف اليها في راس السنه
الصينيه في الثانيه والعشرين من يناير
وعادتنا الصينيين بيكونوا مشغولين بهذه
الفتره لذلك ربما الوفد الصيني ليس بكبير
همم الوفد الاوروبي رؤساء التنفيذيين
للشركات الاورو ايضا ربما ليسوا كثيرين
ولكن كما تحدثنا هناك حضور قوي من دول
اخرى رؤساء جنوب افريقيا اسبانيا من
المنطقه العربيه ايضا حدود السعوديه وكذلك
الى الامارات
فبالتالي كيف يمكن النظر للطبيعات هذه
المشاركه الى ايضا النظره ربما من المنتدى
السعوديه الان مع تغير والتطور الكبير
الذي تشهده في كافه المجالات من خاصه من
النواحي الاقتصاديه
خالد مشاركه قويه للسعوديه حتى في اجنحه
تسوق لهذه المشاريع الضخمه وللمؤسسات في
السعوديه مثلا سوف نذهب بعد قليل لجناح
لمؤسسه مسك الخيريه التي تدعم الشباب
السعودي هنا فرصه للسعوديه للقاء رؤساء
تنفيذيين خبره الشركات للتسويق لمشاريعا
ضخمه ولجذب الاستثمارات الضخمه السعوديه
يعني الجانب الرسمي من المشاركين ولكن
ايضا هناك رؤساء تنفيذيين لكره الشركات
لارامكو همم سابك حتى ارامكو هون الملفت
هذا العام في قريه بالمرس للمنتدى قريه
هدف التعاون في مسؤولين بيدخلوا على
القريه عبر الافاتارز ارامكو مثلا عند
جناح بهذه القريه تستعرض فيها مشاريعه من
الطاقه المتجدده حسب فهمه هنا فهمناه ايضا
هناك مبادره سوف تكون بين السعوديه وبين
المنتدى لخلق مجلس يدعم الابتكار داخل
السعوديه وبالتالي هناك مشاركه قويه هذه
السنه من المملكه
الى اخبار الرياضه الان مع ديمه محمد
السادس
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك يا خالد ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا احرز
برشلونه كاس السوبر الاسبانيه بعد فوزه
على ريال مدريد بثلاثه اهداف لهدف على
ملعب الملك فهد في العاصمه السعوديه
الرياض تفاصيل المباراه في التقرير التالي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
كرنفالون في استاد الملك فهد بالرياض
بحضور نحو 70 الف متفرج احتجدوا لدعم
برشلونه وريال مدريد المدرب الايطالي في
مواجهه مع الاسباني تشافي هيرنانديز
الفرنسي كريم بنزيما وجها لوجه مع
الكتلوني بوسكيت كل هذا على الاراضي
السعوديه
نهائي كاس السوبر الاسباني
برشلونه يكرر المحاوله وراسيه ليفاندوفسكي
تظل طريق المرمى
الفريق الكتالوني اكثر خطوره في المره
الاولى الدفاع يتصدق وفي الثانيه القائم
يدافع عن الكتيبه البيضاء وفي النهايه
الكره الى خارج المستطيل الاخضر ريال
مدريد يرد بهذه المحاوله عن طريق مندي
الذي ارسل كره لكريم بنزيما والاخير لا
ينجح في الوصول الى المرمى
يتلاعبوا في الدفاعات المدريديه كان ذلك
قبل ان تهدر الكتيبه الكتالونيه فرصه
التقدم
[تصفيق]
برشلونه يستغلها الدفاعيه مدريديه لتصل
الكره الى جافي والاخير يسجل الهدف الاول
للفريق الكتلوني
[تصفيق]
بعدها بقليل ليفاندوفسكي يكشر عن انيابه
قبل ان يضاعف النتيجه بهدف ثامن في مرمى
ريال مدريد
في الشوط الثاني ديمبلي كان قريبا من
اضافه الثالث لبرشلونه وكرتوا يتعلق في
التصدي هذه المره
[تصفيق]
والاخير
بجلوسه على دكه البدلاء بعدها بقليل
برشلونه يوصل زحفه نحو اللقب بتسجيل الهدف
الثالث عن طريق بادري
[تصفيق]
ريال مدريد يحاول تقليص النتيجه في اول
لقطه مقربه
[تصفيق]
محاوله جديده للريال واشتيجن يحافظ على
نظافه الشباكه كان هذا قبل ان يقلص كريم
بنزيما الفارق بتسجيل هدف شرفي لريال
مدريد
هدف لم ينل من انتصار برشلونه الكاسح
وفوزه بكاس السوبر الاسباني
هدى زين الدين العربيه
[تصفيق]
على وقع الكلاسيكو الاسباني فهد الشهري
رصد الاجواء
[موسيقى]
حياك الله الله يحييك يا هلا مرحبا
ان شاء الله اليوم برشلونه
هتكون قويه من الطرفين باذن الله بعيد عن
اجواء انك انت مين بتشجع او لمين اي فريق
تنتمي الاجواء جميله بشكل عام المباراه
باذن الله مدريديه ان شاء الله بصراحه
الحمد لله يفوز ريال مدريد
همم المره هذه برشلونه يتفوق شويه همم
ريال مدريد يعني تم حاجه ههه وبرشلونه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ضد برشلونه فريق اخر برشلونه عقده ريال
مدريد
العاصمه لشبونه تعادل بافيكا مع سبورتينغ
بهدفين لمثلهما في الاسبوع السادس عشر من
الدوري البرتغالي في الدقيقه السابع
والعشرين افتتح سبورتينغ التسجيل عن طريق
الكسندر الذي سجل بالخطا في مرمى فريقه
وفي الدقيقه السابعه والثلاثين عادل
نتيجه لبان في كابيراسي الهدف الاول هو مع
انطلاق الشوط الثاني استعراض سبورتاج
تقدمه بهدف سجله
وعاد دراما 64 واحرز هدف التعادل الثاني
لبابا وبهذه نتيجه حافظها على صداره
الترتيب بفريق اربع نقاطعه الذي يليه في
الترتيب
وفي مباراه ثانيه فاز بورتو على فاميلي
كاو باربعه اهداف مقابله هدف ضمن منافسات
الاسبوع السادس عشر من الدوري البرتغالي
وفي الدقيقه العاشره افتتحق بورتو التسجيل
عن طريق جنين وفي الدقيقه الواحده
والعشرين عاد نفس اللاعب وعزز من التقدم
بورتو بهدف ثالث وقبل ثلاث دقائق بنهايه
الشوط الاول سجل اتعبير الهدف الثالث
لبورتو ومع بدايه الشوط الثاني اضاف مهدي
الاهداف وحمل اهداف
الوحيد اسم رايفون في الدقيقه ال 50 وبهذا
الفوز رفع بورتو رصده الى 36 نقطه المركزي
الثالث هو بيفائقي 50 نقاط عن بانفيكا
المتصدر
يلتقي المنتخب العماني مساء اليوم مع
نظيره البحريني في نصف نهائي كاس الخليج
المقامه حاليا في البصره العراقيه
المباراه ستجمع بطلي اخر نسختين من
البطوله بعد ما حققت البحرين لقبها الاول
نسخه 2019 في قطر وقبلها فازت عمان بلقب
الثاني من ارض الكويت عام 2017 وكانت
مواجهه المنتخب الماضيه من كاس الخليج
انتهت بالتعادلي بلا اهداف في ما انتصرت
عمان بثلاثيه نظيفه في دور المجموعات من
كاس العربيه الاخيره
على باقي هذا الخبر نختم ونعود الان الى
زميل خالد
[موسيقى]
السعوديه الذي يعيش درجات حراره تقترب من
الصفر ينضم الينا من هناك مراسل العربيه
جدا متجمد
احدث الكويت
في درجات الحراره بشكل اكثر همم
توقعات كبيره بتساقط الثلوج لهذا اليوم
وخاصه في الساعات القادمه طبعا من خلال
الكاميرا العربيه سواء الكاميرا التي
نلتقطعها من الجو وهكذلك الكاميرا التي
تشاهدونها الان هناك بعض همم ثلوج التي
تساقطت على بعض مرتفعات قمم جبل اللوز في
منطقه نيوم وكذلك انه يشاهد الان تكون من
السحب الممطره التي هي ايضا متوقع بعدها
ان يكون هناك تساقط للثلوج ان يتحدث على
همم او نقف على ارتفاع يصل الى متر عن سطح
البحر وفي منطقه ايضا تشهد بالكثير من
التضاريس متنوعه خاصه في ظل اهتمام اليوم
بها في همم في المشاريع وكذلك في تحديث
بعض جمالياتها ولكن الاهم في هذه هذا
الامر هو اا ال- ال- ال- الذي الموجه
الثالثه المتوقعه التي ينتظرها اهالي نيوم
او كذلك الزوار والسياح الذين انقدموا
صراحه اليوم يمكن نجاهد من الامارات وكذلك
بعضهم من قدم من خارج السعوديه من بعض
الدول العربيه الذي نوصلوا الى هذه القمه
بعد سلسله من التوقعات في الاسبوع الماضي
بتساقط الثلوج لهذا اليوم همم الخبراء
الطقس يتحدثون ان همم
يكون التساقط التساقط الثلوج ما بين
الساعه السادسه مساء بتوقيت المحلي
السعودي الى الساعه 10:00 من مساء هذا
اليوم وكذلك ايضا همم تكون او سوف يكون
تساقط
بيبدا بشكل خفيف حتى يبدا همم شكل اكبر مع
مساء هذا اليوم همم في كل الاحوال ايضا
درجات الحراره منخفضه نتحدث عن درجه واحده
هي تلامس همم تقريبا ايضا الصفر في ظل
ايضا توقعات بان تصل الى اثنين تحت الصفر
في ساعات متاخره من مسائي هذا اليوم همم
على ايضا الصوره هناك بعض المتنزهين الذين
هم المتنزهين الذين قدموا الى قمه جبل
اللوز بعد سماعهم للاخبار التي تداولت عن
تساقط الثلوج لهذا اليوم وبعد ايضا ما
تداوله خبراء الطقس وكذلك التحذيرات
المستمر من مركز الارصاد الجوي السعودي عن
هطول امطار غزيره في هذه المنطقه مع تساقط
الثلوج لهذا اليوم لن انسى ايضا ان هناك
جهات حكوميه وكذلك امنيه تشرف على حركه
وصول السيا وكذلك الزوار والمتنزهين الى
هذه المنطقه هو كذلك استعدادات من قبل همم
المديريه العامه للدفاع المدني همم في همم
المنطقه همم لحاله لحاله اي همم اجراءاتك
اي اجراءات او ايضا امنيه واحترازيه وايضا
في حاله همم مساعده لبعض من قد يتعثر خاصه
انها قمه جبل اللوز هناك طريق ممهد وبعض
الزوار والسياح في اثناء تساقط الثلوج
يقوم بسلك هذه الطرق التي قد تؤدي مركبته
الى الانزلاق بسبب كثره الثلوج وكذلك بعض
شده البرود على الطريقه السفيرتي مثل ما
حدث في الموجات الماضيه عموما ايضا ان ما
زلنا ننتظر هذه الموجه الثالثه ونشاهد
ايضا دخول همم ركام سحابيه بشكل اكبر
قادمه من الجهه الغربيه وهي تتجه نحو
او تتجه نحو الشرق كما نشاهدها الان ونحن
نرصدها عبر الكاميرات التي همم
الموجوده والتي تمتلكها العربيه في مثل
هذه الاجواء وهي من الحالات النادره
والرصد النادر التي تلتقطها كقناه
تلفزيونيه وترصد قناه تلفزيونيه مثل هذه
الاجواء خاصه كمنطقه مثل منطقه نيوم
الواقعه شمال غرب السعوديه شكرا لك من جبل
اللوز مراسل العربيه
يعطيك العافيه
الاوديه تنقسم لقسمين منابع ومجامع وجميع
الاوديه في السعوديه مجامع لمياه الامطار
تقويم مع خالد الزعيم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاوديه عباره عن منابع او مجامع وجميع
الاوديه لدينا عباره عن مجامع لمياه
الامطار فهي احواض تجمع مياه الامطار
الساقطه عليها والامطار تنقسم الى قسمين
امطار محليه تكون في بقعه دون ثانيه وهذه
هي التي تمشي ثعبان والشعبان اصغر من
الاوديه وامطار عامه وهي التي تشمل عددا
من المناطق وهي التي تمشي الاوديه وعندنا
عدد من الاوديه عالميه وطويله وعظيمه وادي
الرمه وادي حنيفه ابن نجد وادي رميه وادي
العقيق وادي فاطمه هذا بالحجاز وادي سرحان
بالجوف وادي حلي وادي جازان وادي عرعر
والاوديه مصدر رئيس من مصادر المياه
الصحيه لنمو الاشجار البريه الطلح والسدر
والغضاء والرمث الا ليت شعرها الابيتن
ليله بجنب الغضا اسجي القلاص النواجي فليت
الغضا لم يقطع الركب عرضه وليس الغضا ما
شركادا لياليا
[موسيقى]
نجحت سلطات والمضيق البسفور في تعويم
سفينه الشحن ام كي كي واحد التي كانت قد
جنحت وتسببت في تعليق حركه الملاحه في
المضيق الحيوي سفينه كانت تحمل 13 الف طن
من الحبوب متجه من اوكرانيا الى تركيا
[تصفيق]
طلبه الرئيس الامريكي جو بايد المحكمه
تنفي ولايه اركانس السلام الامريكيه بمنع
ابنته البالغه من العمر اربع سنوات من حمل
اسمه وذلك بعد اشهر قليل من رفع هنتر دعوه
قضائيه لخفض مدفوعات اعاده طفلته التي
انجبها من لندن روبرتس في عام 2018
للطفل النافع عن طريق اختبار الحمض النووي
اعلنت قوات الدرك في ايطاليا اعتقال
الهارب رقم واحد زعيم المافيا المدان
ماتيو مسينا ديمارو وذلك بعد 30 عاما من
الفرق وتم القبض عليه في عياده خاصه في
باليرمو بجزيره صقليه
يصف ايران بالتحدي لكم
ده بوست استعد للمنتدى الاقتصادي العالمي
للمشاركه افضل سعودي رفيع برئاسه وزير
الخارج
الرابعه والثقوليه الترجمه في القضاء
السعودي 47 لغه لتسهيل فهم المتقاضين
للاحكام
وضمن مبادره ضخمه بدو عمليات التشجير في
ساحات ومرافق المسجد الحرام
عام مليء بالاحداث الرياضيه في السعوديه
برشلونه بطل السوبر وختام والدكان
[موسيقى]